اه نوه بان المصابان او المصابين باطلاق
النار قربه سلوان في حاله خطره احدهما
فاقد للوعي هذا بحسب الاذاعه اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي كنت تتحدث وليد عن
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه حكومه
نتنياهو التي توصف بانها الاكثر تطرفا في
تاريخ اسرائيل تداعيات ما يجري تداعيات
هذا التصعيد على الحكومه الحديثه في تركيا
من اطرافها وكانها تحقق الامن المطلق
للاسرائيليين وان الفلسطينيين سيكون
خانعينا ومستسلمين الان في هذا هجوم الامس
واليوم رغم انها قامت بعمليه واسعه في
جنين وقتلت عدد كبير من الفلسطينيين واضح
بان حساباتها قد انقلبت عليها حتى في نظر
الاسرائيليين انفسهم الذين يرونها بان
المزيد من القوه لا يعني بانك ستتحقق
الامن ما دام هناك همم امل الامل في حال
سلمي غير قائم بعدين انت لا تعترف بالاخر
انه اصلا من البشر لان الصهيونيه الدينيه
التي تتحكم في هذه الحكومه ونتنياهو على
ما يبدو لا يستطيع ان يرفض لهم طلب هذه
الصهيونيه دينيه تدرك جيدا بانها تحاول ان
تطبق ايديولوجيتها على اساس ثورات وان
تبدا بقدمه وضمي اجزاء من دي الغربيه
وانهاء الفلسطينيه والوجود الوطني
الفلسطيني هذا يبدو انه يبدا باقناع بعض
الاسرائيليين بانهم اخطاوا عندما اعتقدوا
ان مزيد من التطرف قد ياتي لهم بالمزيد من
الامن الان الوضع كما نرى ليس في الضفه
الغربيه وحده الوضع هو في القدس وعندما
نتحدث عن القدس سواء بالحي الاستيطان
يعقوب او بلده سلوان المقتظه بالبرد
الاستيطانيه جميعها خاضعه بالكامل لسيطره
الاحتلال بكافه ادواته وبكافه قدراته